in lighter news
[Laughter]
because it can't always be doom and
gloom
and anger and vitriol and resentment
toward the other side and their
anti-democracy
remember this tweet from elon musk
back in uh july 12 2021
those who attack space
maybe don't realize that space
represents hope for so many people
[Laughter]
listen say what you will about lily
elon musk i have said a lot i am not
his biggest fan i don't think he is an
existential threat though um
this news is hilarious elon musk to
launch a satellite
keep how about this keep that in mind
keep that tweet in mind as i read this
story
uh that that people who attack space
maybe don't realize that space
represents
hope for so many people elon musk to
launch a satellite that will beam
advertisements into space
the venture is a combined effort between
canadian technology startup geometric
energy corporation
and spacex
[Laughter]
so space doesn't just represent hope it
also represents
advertising which is hilarious because
this is about as
uh low-tech as it gets it sounds
a canadian technology startup will be
partnering with elon musk's
spacex to make space advertisements
a thing of the future according to a
report by business insider
samuel reed the ceo and co-founder of
geometric energy corporation gec
told the outlet that the company is
working to create a satellite called
cubesat real cool
one side of the cubesat will be used to
promote arts
excuse me ads art and logos
people and companies will be able to pay
to place their ads there
by buying pixels on the display screen
with
cryptocurrency the gec
is planning on launching cubesat into
space via one of
musk's musk muskas spacex falcon 9
rockets
which will release it into orbit in
space before the
rocket heads to the moon big news
all right here's where it gets just
[Music]
chef's kiss hilarious
reed said
come on man reed said a
selfie stick will be attached to the
cubesat
filming the display screen and allowing
people on earth
to watch it
allowing people on earth to watch it on
a live stream
through youtube or twitch
so if you thought this was gonna be like
a massive
uh a massive screen like a billboard in
space that you could see from earth
it's not that it's a selfie stick with a
camera pointing back at it
and you're gonna have to go to youtube
to actually witness the ads
so yeah um many people don't realize
that space
represents hope
thanks for joining me you guys i'm jesse
dalmore sitting in for david pakman
see you next time